this is super interesting as you may
know they're remaking Disney is remaking
Snow White this video is actually from
September of 22. the actress who will be
playing Snow White her name is Rachel
zegler she was interviewed with Wonder
Woman what's Wonder Woman's name Gal
Gadot on a red carpet and they were
asking her about this new what this new
character is going to be like
you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it unsaid what do you mean by that I
just mean that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely wrote a snow white that is
not going to be saved by the prince
she's not gonna be saved for The Prince
and she's not going to be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in Snow White is running for
president
I'm launching my campaign okay so you
may be watching that and go well there's
nothing really wrong with that there's
no nothing wrong with a girl thinking
that she can go be fearless and lead the
world and all those things and of course
you are right so what's the problem well
what do you have to do you got to peel
that layer and then just look a little
bit deeper and then you figure out
what's wrong with it there is nothing
wrong with the story in the first place
the idea that this girl met the prince
accomplished her dreams fell in love
blah blah blah so instead of destroying
everything that is old just destroying
Snow White but we saw that the Seven
Dwarfs are no longer dwarfs you got
rapey and Dopey and and angry and
all the rest of them instead of
destroying everything from the past
which the woke are extremely good at
doing how about you just create a new
story why didn't Disney just create a
new story with a great strong
interesting female lead and and make it
everything that the actress would like
it to be if that if that's the right way
to go about doing it by the way you can
make stories like that and you can make
stories about a traditional princess
etc etc but they try to destroy
everything and then once all of the
stuff all of our stories you Rampage
through the the biblical stories you
Rampage through all of our cultural
stories whether it's Disney movies or
Star Wars or whatever any of the stuff
that can bring any of us together music
we'll get to that in just a moment once
you destroy all of that well then we
have nothing else that brings us
together and then you wonder why
everybody's looking at everybody going
oh you're black you're gay ah problem
it's a problem
[Music]